hi I'm Audrey Whitby and i'm meghan
downlink and I'm Gracie to sunny and I'm
Teala Dunn and we are the girls of I i
well basically i mo is like a girl talk
show like it's basically like the talk
but for tweens yeah we got to be
Goldberg hey we talk about things like
fashion and confidence and I wise we do
DIYs and hair challenge hair challenges
yeah and we just talked about you know
just a new where's Justin Bieber wonder
about what your friction within the
social media world most of all we talk
about though boy boy tubers we have like
some guess youtubers stars sometimes oh
it's political I also address some
things that are prevalent in the media
and in are happening it's happening it
to happen they're happening to teens in
this world I do we cover a lot of like
are bullying very anti bullying all of
us yeah so okay I just cover all the fun
stuff we do the deep stuff too yeah
awesomeness helps that a lot and
sometimes we come up with our own like I
know Gracie's come up with a lot of our
like do it yourself attractive eyes do
it do it ourselves I've come up with but
then a lot of the times after we do one
episode we all get that like other ideas
like oh my gosh we just talked about
Emma Stone why don't we do a whole
episode about amazed LOL yeah as we come
up with our girl crush episodes own girl
crush mila kunis girls Emma Watson with
jobs I love me stress mine Kristen Wiig
was mine we each have like cried on the
side of AI moi cries at your child too I
cried because I was really sick and then
I was just bawling so I cranked as a
shot of Rosie and I kind of yeah because
I'm such a huge like oh like SNL fan and
Amy Poehler got to be like a little
video
that thing with IMO it was Angie said
heyyyy Audrey what I cried I love her so
the thing I haven't traveled it back
embarrassing so work on it I think over
the past five months we've really become
close friends especially through social
media we've stayed in touch via Facebook
and Twitter I'll try now whatever Hagen
is sick I know everything about all of
them because of like there Twitter and
their Facebook in their YouTube channels
it's always like like is for me I live
in New York so it's almost an a all most
of them live here or at least most of
the time they live here so I feel like
the outcasts but in a way I don't
because through social media I feel like
you know they all like Oh Meghan you're
sick feel better or like this happened
this and that it's almost when we come
back we don't miss anything I felt like
I miss nothing of course coming into
being 16 and the first time I came in
here they'd already kind of known each
other a little bit especially Megan and
Gracie and so I've kind of walked in an
environment that was like I'm a little
bit intimidated by these many girls it's
all I like but I think it's the time
that we've all spent together is really
I think that's why people keep watching
IMO because they keep getting better
because as we get closer and closer
inspection times are changin episode
together nice literally like we're best
friends sitting on a couch talking yeah
yeah and like me like I like just came
in to imal and like I kind of knew
pretty much a lot of you guys before
beforehand and but I did kind of meat
like Bethenny you you as well I'm a
highly important is if I we actually
taught me a lot over today yeah and then
I'll finally matter so then I felt like
I kind of knew everybody but I feel like
as time goes on we're getting so much
closer my show Supah Ninjas actually
shoots five days a week like 12 hours a
day so I'm used to a pretty long
schedule and I'm used to doing scenes
over and over again and then when I got
to the site was so interesting that we
can get so many topics covered and we
can do so much takes like 30 minutes to
shoot one episode and we're just going
through so many topics at once and then
it's so you should I'm so used to doing
multiple takes and then to come here and
just you like one take and be done and
so great
and I think also this is more
instantaneous and like the fans get to
see it right away and then today I dress
up like the next it's like wait we just
shot that I've done like I did a sketch
comedy show on Disney Channel and I've
done a few episodes on other sitcoms and
besides the immediate like I'm playing a
character and here I'm being myself
that's sort of something that you have
to learn how to turn on and turn off
like well in front of this camera I'm
somebody else but in front of this
camera I have to turn it off and just be
myself yeah so that's a times hard it is
hard about cuz like you to train
yourself to be a certain way so coming
here was it's definitely like a relaxing
almost experience to be able to sit down
and talk about what you're really
thinking without a script in your hand
yeah I filmed a TV show called are we
there it's on TBS and now sometimes it
comes on the CW as well but like what's
really weird about our shows that we
feel into three episodes a week so we
would film like a lot and like I mean it
would be really really fun but we would
just do so much and like here we do a
lot to in like a day but I just feel
like also here like one I get to do
myself just like Audrey set but it's
also like it just doesn't feel like work
at all you know because I work so much
you know so many hours and everything
with here I just like to get to just be
myself it's like fun and one thing I
realized about the show so because I'm
obviously I'm not an actress so but I
realized something about the show it's
very raw like there's no like you said
there's no scripts there's nothing that
we have to say there's nothing it's just
it's just us it's just us sitting on a
couch talking with our best friends
that's all it is and there's nothing
that we have to say or we have to say
because that's what the people want no
we give our personal opinions but that's
what's so jump on I say things that yeah
I don't like yeah but make this like I'm
via hate we sometimes get low but just
know it's us like yeah but it's not
hosted or not
anyone else